on s'offre encore en ukraine cette
semaine des brioches de pâques même au
porte-parole de l'armée de la région de
zaporijia le colonel yves en arrêt fief
ce qui est surprenant c'est que la
sirène d'alert sûrs d personne ne fait
attention on s'habitue d'autant plus
surprenant pour nous que la veille trois
missiles russes ont été lancés sur la
ville il nous montre la vidéo de celui
qui a détruit une usine et tué une
personne les russes ont affirmé qu'elles
convenait de l'armement de l'otan fodil
colones était une aluminerie désaffecté
imaginez l'explosion si c'était des
armements il ne resterait rien t'as qu'à
keur
strates comme les russes ont d'énormes
pertes ils n'arrivent pas à percer alors
il s'attaque à l'infrastructure civile
le colonel n'hésite pas à prédire que
les russes vont perdre la guerre si
leurs armes et prendra la même direction
que leur bateau elle va couler une image
que la propagande ukrainienne répand on
voit ici le kremlin en train de couler
comme le croiseur moskva
les deux autres missiles n'ont pas fait
de dommage mais là a explosé tout près
de chez notre interprète le bruit était
et est immense surtout de la troisième
explosion
pour la première fois je jette
je ne suis pas comment expliquer je ne
prenais pas des paroles pour expliquer
la peur ressentie
zaporizhya est une des villes clés les
plus importantes pour les rues s'ils
veulent franchir le grand fleuve nièvre
et progresser vers le nord et l'ouest
raison de plus pour que les ukrainiens
la défendent avec le plus grand
acharnement la ville n'est qu'à 30 km du
front et un de ces grands problèmes
c'est l'afflux de réfugiés en provenance
entre autres de marioupol la ville
martyre de ben laden
dès le premier jour de la guerre à
groupe de jeunes de la ville ont mis sur
pied une organisation d'entr'aide
remarquable elle commence avec un centre
d'appels qui trient les dons et les
demandes dead
le théâtre des jeunes s'est transformé
en un énorme entrepôt où des volontaires
recueil ensuite distribuer du matériel
et tous les produits et objets et
imaginables d'abord aux soldats et
ensuite aux réfugiés
ici c'est la pharmacie gérés par des
étudiants en médecine avec au fond les
produits de pédiatrie
les vêtements la nourriture tout est
répertorié systématiquement rien n'est
gaspillé ici des aliments venus de
grande bretagne mais aussi israël et
d'espagne de gros donateurs et
d'allemagne la communauté ukrainienne du
canada contribue beaucoup dit constantin
le cerveau de cette organisation
spectaculaire
c'est très compliqué dit-il on à
automatiser le processus avec un système
de réception et de livraison des
commandes rapides et efficaces ce qui
lui manque
ok des sous vêtements des t-shirts et
produits d'hygiène et le transport pour
évacuer les gens mais surtout pas de
vêtements ils en ont reçu trop
[Applaudissements]
ici on fabrique aussi des filets de
camouflage pour l'armée en quantité
industrielle
tous les matins dans le restaurant jobs
des cuisiniers assistant tous bénévoles
préparent des repas pour l'armée
deux ou trois autres restaurants en
ville et des centaines dans tout le pays
font la même chose
au début de la guerre de maxime on
préparait mille repas par jour on a
réduit à quatre cent cinquante maisons
livres seulement aux soldats du front il
a besoin de plus de produits
alimentaires et de volontaires
l'après-midi jobs redevient un restants
ce genre de mobilisation spontanée s'est
fait dès le premier jour à l'échelle de
toute l'ukraine jean michel leprince du
canada sapowicz